oh my god this summer is so awesome How
to Train Your Dragon 2 Joe How to Train
Your Dragon 2 if you couldn't tell is a
sequel to how to train your dragon I
know it's hard to piece together but
that's what it is and how to train your
dragon hiccup met up with toothless the
dragon they became a pair and now
everyone's friends with dragon in this
movie there's a big douchebag out there
who's making an army of dragons and now
they gotta stop up yeah the movies
deeper than that but I'm not gonna spoil
that for you c'mon we're all about class
on my show is this movie good you
couldn't tell seriously when I give an
intro like oh my god this summer is so
awesome means it's probably pretty good
first of all it looks great I mean the
cinematography is great when they're
flying around on their dragons the
cameras following him around I saw it in
2d because I'm on this personal vendetta
against the 3d movement at this point
but it impressed me I felt like I was up
there so I imagine in 3ds blows your
mind and the computer animation just
looks solid there's this one scene it's
a big piece of land and a ship and it
was a Far Away shot it's one of those
establishing shots and I was like that
looks like live action it looks like
it's a live action movie
there's just the visuals my friends deep
down this movie is something else this
movie takes the characters to the next
level as a proper sequel should do
hiccup in the first movie was you know
the boy was the boy hiccup and he found
a dragon this one he has to become the
man this is one of the things that
reminded me of The Lion King in this
movie I walked out of there go this
might be the Lion King of this
generation the actions really exciting
in this movie there are touching moments
I think I almost teared up like three
times real men cry in movies that are
animations probably made for children
but also made for adults
I mean adults will love this movie
because there are themes that really hit
adults kids who like the movie because
it's a fun action movie that has cool
dragons honestly for every age group you
can be like this movie is gonna appeal
to everybody I'll be that movie that
kids see and then they're gonna love it
and then they grow up and they
understand some of the tones and the
emotional moments that the movie was
going for so they appreciate the movie
on a whole other level and they'll be
like How to Train Your Dragon 2 is the
greatest animation ever made and I'm
like I am glad you have that to
experience like me and The Lion King
there are a couple of moments where it
takes steps and it doesn't pander like
oh we could just you know be the nerf
bat here but no we're not going to this
is what happens in situations like this
and here you go here is some stuff you
can see how clipped my wings are trying
to talk about
movie not spoiler for you guys I'll put
it this way I had to pee so bad do the
entire movie and I was like oh I can't
go now because it's really exciting I'll
wait till the action seems done and then
the dialogue scenes hit I was like no
this is really touching stuff and it's
really good and it's establishing the
characters and the I can't go now and
then the next scene was an action city
it was just it was like that there's no
opportune time in this movie to get up
leave the movie theater and pay that's
how you know it's a really good movie I
really want there to be a third movie
because I want to see where it goes but
I don't know that a third one can be
better than this one this movie
literally had everything in it had great
characters I had a good relationship
between toothless and hiccup I mean if
you own a pet and I do I was like you're
gonna connect with that and the movie
revolves around family and
responsibilities and obligation and
stepping up and taking down really evil
douchebags who build armies of dragons
cuz they're just the bad people it's
only natural to compare this movie to
other animations I will phrase it like
this I liked how to train your dragon to
better than the lego movie I liked how
to train your dragon to better than
frozen no I'm just saying I'm saying I'd
liked it better than frozen it did you
like what you want there was one thing
there was one scene one thing that
happened in this movie that did bring
the movie down slightly and it's the
part when it ends as in the movie when
the movie ends I didn't want it to end
because How to Train Your Dragon 2 is
absolutely awesome tacular
great characters great heart great
emotion great action really exciting and
Dragons because I had a train to Dragon
- have you seen it what did you think
about it I know I'm really up talking
this movie up here but I was just so
impressed with it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more